By the time that the pizza man came,...
...everyone had all gone to bed.
When the dog food finally arrived,...
...the dog had already been fed.
Why is everybody always late?
When the man on the television said,...
...the weather was about to get bad.
Well, it had already been raining and snowing for so long.
I didn't even get mad.
Why is everybody always late?
When you asked me for a ride back home,...
...I had already sold my car.
And when you asked me if I needed a ride,...
...I had already walked too far.
Why is everybody always late?
When the quarterback finally threw...
...his very last touchdown pass,...
...the other team had already gone home.
There was nobody left on the grass.
Why is everybody always late?
When Johnny came home to tell his wife,...
...he was sorry for what he had said.
He saw a note sitting on the kitchen table.
A note he had never read and it said, it said,...
..."Why is everybody always late?"
"You're late, Johnny!"